all right I'm going to open the
subcommittee work session or reopen you
know it's on the continuing subcommittee
work session on House Bill 1271 and um
so we had been working uh on the
guardian at Lim board I know we got
um uh some good input from
representative
Gould and I sent
um there were two emails out one was
response to that but
um let me find it here it's
assignment
scheduling Oh Long folder that's why
sorry
um so I sent out an email which was uh
in the form that I would
have sent to uh the partial draft
Amendment for House Bill 1271 thank you
um which I think took in all of the
changes that we had uh discussed and
um and I don't know uh repr G if you had
a chance to look at on the second page
of the email the part dealing with the
membership of Guardian at Liam I tried
to reflect what I understood of what you
wanted actually mostly copied it so does
that look okay it looked good I I think
Doug was going to look at Lang anguage
for that lawyer
um a guardian at lium who was a member
of the bar is the way I put it but there
might be better language than that yeah
if you could come up
uh and I didn't send this out to a lot
of people I sent it to the people on the
subcommittee but I probably should have
sent it to you but the current the the
the proposed language and this is um
would you like me to give them my copy
that I had mailed out this is youa yeah
great so it's um the top of the third
page of
that where goes one member who is a bar
member and who page two three yeah page
oh you I gave him so top of the back
page is where he's at is this the same
as the oh you just you just removed the
I didn't give them the front Okay cool
right I don't know where it is on that
copy but it's um the section that that
490-2186
and I think the other language is pretty
much um
statute was some removals yes I just
wanted to go back to I brought this up
at the full um board too yesterday full
committee too um I I do have a is
concern with putting executive director
I know we moved it from board to if we
can keep the office as a consistency is
what in other places I actually um if
you look at the the amendment I sent
yeah um it changed it to executive
director everywhere because that's
what's in the rest of Statute and and if
you have a you can't you can't assign a
responsibility to an office you have to
assign it to a person and she is the
director of the office so really it in
effect it has to be the same that
doesn't mean she's going to do
everything she'll she has staff all that
but but the language that's in the rest
of the statute is um the executive
director so the existing statute has
executive director correct and I think
it's just a drafting error that they
they like over half they put executive
director in some places they did
office and I went through it because if
you look at bracket board bracket where
they're replacing there's like 145
occurrences in here correct and I went
through them mall and what I'm telling o
op OS is that anyone Works bracket board
bracket office to change it to executive
director to be consistent with the other
statute so but in the Statue existing
statue has board correct so because
that's what we are trying to change to
make it advisory but in the existing
statute elsewhere where there are there
are existing advisory boards so for the
other advisory boards the language and
statute is executive director not
office now does executive board no I
mean Advisory Board and Ru making
statutory board or licensing board that
had the ability to license that was
moved last year and that is the concern
where the statue uh if there is a
conflict that still has the board
regulatory board versus right OPC
getting that is that I I'm that's where
my confusion is so in existing statute
where there are where some of the boards
are advisory boards
today then the language doesn't have
board in there it has executive director
and it doesn't say
office okay so if we're going to change
some these to Advisory Board then what
we need to do is change board to
executive director some places in the
this bill it has it but other places in
the bill it's replacing board with
office and that's not correct okay so
you clarified one doubt that is only if
the statutary board is becoming ex um ad
Advisory Board then the executive
director needs to be in place of the
board correct if it still stays as a
statutory board not all 57 boards are
converting that into Advisory Board am I
correct so if it is a statutary board
then we don't need to do the executive
director we're not dealing with all the
boards we're only dealing with the ones
that this bill deals with right now so
yeah which is advisory trying change we
we're not going to try and change the
Board of Medicine to an Advisory board
or anything so that yeah but it has on
a we can turn the mic on and introduce
yourself I guess I have one
recommendation for Section D and I'm
putting something together for Section d
section D okay minor change won't change
the meeting just uh okay yeah if you
could uh email that to me and then I'll
update this I have just hand it back to
oh you have the language yeah I just did
it right now okay yeah if you can get
that to us
I'll D on the amendment on the email I
sent the email that said draft partial
Amendment for
HB oh it okay so right now it says one
member meaning member of the board who
is a bar member and who is experienced
as an appointed Guardian of Light I'm
appointed by the executive director and
he's
clarifying uh a bar a a a bar of the New
Hampshire a me who is a new member of
the New Hampshire bar associ so it's a
member of what first bar I ever passed
[Laughter]
what I'm not going to talk what kind of
level the bar is T is bar and okay no
change Mr chair if I can just um make a
comment to Doug he's working on the
language for the the line we had that
was one member of the Child Protection
Agency uh member and I was trying to
find what in statute so I I tried to
look at our any of those other I was
confused at the last meeting when I said
Easter Seals Easter Seals was a child
placement agency at one point which I
don't think they still are that's
different than a Child Protection Agency
and so I didn't know what language to
use that would Encompass both DCF and
other things like KY program and in
looking around at various the Child
Protection Systems seem to be a term but
legally I don't know that's your yeah I
right I'm trying to think of a word
because agency to me makes me think more
official like a state agency uh system
I'm not sure is the right word so I'm
just trying to find one word to plug in
organization how about Child Protection
Organization which could be a state
organiz state agency or a private KC
Foundation is a private nonprofit but
it's an organization that would I think
that would do it that would cover yeah
Easter Seals cac's yeah I think that
organization would be a good yeah Easter
Seals is not a protection agency it's
more a placement and provider of
programs for right so casy Foundation is
similar to dcyf a private
representing
that's okay all right so
um with the the changes that were in
that email I sent and the two changes we
just
discussed
um I'd like a motion on
adopting the guardian and Lim section so
this is um you
know can I raise one more issue before
you move on not to slow things down
there's a repeal the 490 C4 is Page and
page and line looking for right 12 page
12 12 12 line 28 is a repeal and replace
it's the duties of the board uh I just
wanted to draw your attention to section
g and I want to make sure everybody's
read that language
before we repeal it entirely we P page
in line again yeah so it's not in the
bill because it's repealed that's why I
want to draw your atten it's dropping
something it's a line across cross it's
a complete real repealing and replace
because the language of the bill is
repealed and reenacted as then you don't
get any line acrosses and it's just and
what does it do so it's um it allows the
board which will change to the executive
director
to at their discretion um what do they
do refer a complaint to the appropriate
court for investigation resolution or
other action uh it's a May the referral
may be made regardless of whether the
allegation or complaint relates to a
case which is then pending in court uh
may be made in Li of or in addition to
any investigatory or disciplinary
procedures that the board May itself be
authorized to
pursue uh gives the board authority to
formally resolve complaints by agreement
which we don't really need because of
310 but then the last sentence is the
one I believe the executive director dor
testified on a complaint relating to a
trial or judicial proceeding in progress
shall be dismissed without prece unless
the board for good cause votes to
proceed
immediately so before before you moved
on I just wanted to make sure you had
eyes on that language um that's that's P
policy dut as I understand it and I
unfortunately we don't have printed
copies for everybody but unless you can
look it up on your phone I pass it
surrounded if you can tell us where to
look up I can look up on sure it's for
490-cfm
so Doug as I understand it these are
duties the board head and when we
repealed the board language to make it
advisory in another bill that is being
looked up we now have these duties
dangling no no this I this one is just
everything else I did like a comparison
everything else in this Duty section is
is in this language that we're seeing
except this section and our big concern
is that it was being interpreted and
rightly so I think that the office
didn't have the ability to follow
through on complaints because of just
the way the language is worded but
there's a little bit more to it to that
it seems to have this kind of Dual
Purpose where you can have the board
investigating a complaint and also the
office I think our concern was with the
very last sentence AR say which one
again I'm uh 490 C4 G one uh Roman one
Roman G all of all of the citation would
be
helpful so I think our concern was with
the last sentence a complaint relating
to a trial or judicial proceedings in
progress shall be dismissed without
prejudice unless the board for good
cause um that was our big concern now
would you still leave at the board well
I actually drafted a proposed
amendment if you decide to keep this
paragraph in I think what's the argument
for keeping it in Lindsay has a I don't
think
there I don't know I don't know that I
think Lindsay has a concern that that
this seems to
be the court interjecting itself in sort
of Family Matters in a inappropriate way
when the board could probably resolve
the issue on its
own so so but but I also think that's a
policy decision but just so I understand
I mean if this becomes an Advisory board
so the board would still be looking at
individual it okay uh represent so I
think the the policy question is whether
or not you want to give us the authority
to refer the matter to the court for a
separate investigation and that's really
the question if you don't then I don't
think we need to change anything in 1271
if you think that we should be able to
make that recommendation we may want to
add either that language back in or and
then I have I also have a proposed
amendment because of that last sentence
it says a complaint relating to a trial
or judicial proceeding in progress shall
be dismissed without Prejudice I drafted
language which I guess is a third option
where you could add just this language
in and it would allow us to stay a
complaint
pending
the conclusion of the proceeding in
court so we could sit on a complaint
without the statute of limitations
tolling but they you're passing it off
to the court yeah I have a draft if you
just excuse me I
minute all right I was just going to ask
if you would translate that last
me so so we have a stat if a complaint
comes in we have a statute of
limitations yeah and looks like one of
the concerns is the complaint process
being weaponized so parents could file a
complaint against the guardian ad item
if we take this section out where under
the regular uh fiveyear statute of
limitations okay what this would do the
language I just proposed would allow us
to stay that procedure so we can just
sit on it and when the court stuff is
done then we can go and do our complaint
investigation and we're not losing that
time in between thank you yep represent
M py yeah
um thank you
um So currently the complaint is when it
comes
from
uh what is it at Liam right or when the
complaint comes from parents or
non-parent general public where does
that get handled well in the current law
it says it shall be dismissed without
prejudice so the complaint complainant
could complain again afterwards after
the proceeding is over unless the board
for good cause votes to proceed
immediately so right now unless there's
good cause the complaints just dismissed
and the complainant would have to bring
it before the board again when the court
stuff is
over so follow up so the board hears the
complaint at this
time board has
the responsibility of responding to
complaints at this
time the step I'm trying to understand
the statue as it is board has the
authority to look at and inform
oplc whether to move forward or not
that's the way it used to work I would
say under the current procedure because
the office has the complaint
investigation we would have to present
it to the board and then they would make
the decision favoring dismissal without
prejudice right
now so I suppose we could still do our
investigation and then bring it to
them but I also one of the concerns too
is that that board doesn't meet all that
often
so I guess the question is is is there
what's the problem with um instead of
holding on to the I if I understand
correctly the options are you hold on to
the
complaint um
and pending the the court thing being
um if basically the office decides the
office could proceed with the complaint
right away but if they think they need
the the results from the court this
would let them wait and deal with the
complaint after the alternative would be
um you know I don't know whe the board
could not act on the complaint if they
think they need to wait for the judicial
thing and then say bring the complaint
after it's all done or or what are the
Alternatives right now it says that it
shall be dismissed so I think they're
supposed to get rid of that complaint I
guess they could sit on it but then you
also have the problem of the statute of
limitations is taking away and the
courts can take a long time right um so
but if they say if they dismiss it can
that complaint be brought again later
yes but it would make somebody file
another complaint okay all right so so
just to follow up on that the thought
process is that the timing right so you
have a statue of uh limitation for five
years so if somebody brought a complaint
and it was dismissed they have you know
and it comes up again within the five
years will that it has to be a separate
file separ complaint okay so this
response to my focus is on timing for
complaints you know who's do checks and
balances if it comes from parent it
comes from DCF it comes from any place
responded that it that has to be we're
going to treat every complaint the same
regardless of the source okay yeah so i'
I'd like to make a motion which is um oh
exective director oh um yeah on your uh
suggested uh change
here we're on you have um unless the
office decides to proceed immediately
would that be the executive director or
office which is executive director okay
thank you thank you for good catch that
seems to be a problem go home
now all right so uh what the motion I'm
making is is that is to adopt
um this proposed amendment to
add I guess add back in or add um 490
c4e with the change we just talked about
of changing office to executive director
um for clarification Mr chair so the
it's not solely on executive director
respons does not fall on correct okay
I'm okay with that represent Brown so uh
and we've talked about this a number
thank you Mr chair a number of times any
anytime in any statute that it says the
commissioner the executive director or
anything of that nature it always gives
them the responsibility but it means it
gets passed down through the staff as
that person may want to to pass that
down so whenever it says that in any
statute it never means that the
commissioner has all those tasks himself
for the executive director that's that's
how it just is is normally worded I
understand there are two different
Capital questions uh you know executive
director as cap capitalized and then
small case so it's individual that's my
understanding when director Courtney
said it has to be a person and that has
to be the executive director so that's
where I have the buck stops at the dor
it's their responsibility but to make
sure it gets done but they don't have to
do the work necessarily right okay um so
we have a motion and a second
um unless we need further discussion can
we move to a vote on this okay everyone
who approves adopting this change um say
I anyone opposed anyone opposed okay all
right
next so we have um a number of changes
beyond what I had sent out and that's
the change to um they're all to 490 the
actually looking it here 490 C thank
you
uh
C let me get the line I actually I need
to get the line numbers here
um
stuff
commission where's the stuff we were
just dealing with uh well the changes to
the membership right here top right we
already dealt with separately but this
last it was C C2 where
C2 unless I've got the wrong
no it's C4 repealed and
reenacted L 26 and 27 and then
DNA okay it's really um
sorry
F
um
okay actually there was a change to the
language I
propose Mr chair yes I had one question
about the Advisory Board versus uh
statut is it a in general or a
particular page in the line to look the
ones that are listed here right all
eight of them that are converting yeah
and uh so what is one of the concerns is
having done a little bit more re
research on it um is if it is an
Advisory
board and the licy or the certificate
holder should use I mean have more
malpractice or
um
um insurance I don't immunity uh
liability immunity for the members of
the board not the members of the board
if that is taken away from the members
yeah I just want a clarification will it
rest on the license the question is does
it make any change to the lenses yes I I
can't see it but I don't I don't think
so I mean as far as the board members
there they have some protections and
other stat
statutes but it I don't think I'm
understanding when the lies either have
a license or they don't and it's not
affected whether it's an advisory or
Stat correct that's correct no but so
the
liability won't shift the liability when
we talked about liability it's nothing
to do with the lenses at all okay the
liabilities was with the board
members correct correct there's no
change to the lenes correct so the board
members if you statutary board they have
Pro liability protection because they're
nominated from the state is that
liability protection is still available
for an Advisory Board member I think
it's even better for the advisory it's
even better for The Advisory board right
didn't we have that conversation about
the con case or somewhere there was a
case yeah you're right because they're
not making the final decision
anymore um they are actually Less open
to liability issues if we make an
Advisory
board so the state is taking up
the resp responsibility for I mean the
antitrust issue is if you have somebody
a market participant so somebody who
works in that field making the decisions
the state doesn't work in the field so
that's not a concern for the State uh
you know anti trust concern there might
be others but and you tell me if I'm
wrong but one more comment sounds good
represent Brown if I might thank you Mr
chair I we briefly touched on this and I
know in the in the original it's it's an
or as well but are we all okay with the
fact that DCF could possibly not be on
this Advisory Board the way it's written
the way it has been written that way too
but you said it generally has been them
but I just are we all good with that I
guess is I I think actually there's not
an or in the final the thing I emailed
out unless I'm looking at the a
different part that you're talking about
says that section is one member
represent presenting a Child Protection
Organization in the state appointed by
the executive director right so it might
not be DCF as my point it could include
DCF or the private organization which is
how it's written now I I'm just saying
for the sake of conversation are we all
okay with that that might be the
case not that's the situation today is
the situation now okay yeah so I am
comfortable if you're asking personally
I am comfortable as long as DCF or a
Protection Organization which is
involved is represented on the board I'm
fine okay so I'm going to make thank you
thank you I'm going to make another uh
motion which is to if you look at the
email I sent uh draft partial
Amendment and this is about the last
major bullet which says replace section
22 page 11 line 35 through page 12 line
25 and that's around the guardian and
Lim part of membership board membership
so the question is are people okay are
the motion is to adopt that with the
changes we've made today which are to
part one C changing it it's it's more
you know changing it from system to to
organization take the the out and then
on uh D updating the language to make it
clear that they they have to be a member
of of the New Hampshire Bar Association
it's kind of a technical thing
um and
[Music]
then then also adding back in what's
going to become 490c for E I guess is
now
G um with the and the basically the
thing we just adopted
okay um so I'm the E is staying right
one member yeah why did you say it's now
G um no now e it used to be G I think no
or okay never mind there's no G never
adopt
I just out of curiosity will the
members on uh the board get a mileage or
I I know without comp it's really not
pertinent to this we need to move on I
apologize but this has taken a lot
longer than I'd hop for good reason
but
um okay I I've made the motion somebody
want to Second
it okay um all those in favor I anyone
opposed okay hearing none that's what
we're going to do okay
um are we the motion is to
adopt um the you know to keep in the
bill the SEC about Guardian at lium With
The Changes we've just voted to do which
is you know all the stuff we've been
discussing
so okay um so that's my motion does
somebody want to Second
it oh all right any discussion I the the
board in uh that that's number three on
the original one right the convert the
guardian at latum board into advisory
yeah did the
membership go down to three or we uh
that was uh we had that discussion but I
wasn't clear we cut it from seven to
five right instead instead of going to
three it's to five okay because we haded
some back in we took out the senator and
the representative right so
um there's no further discussion all in
favor I anyone opposed all right all
right thank you we are done with the
guardian at Lim board and we're going to
move
on to the uh manufactured housing
installation Standards Board um and I
think first we have a couple people I'll
let you folks uh go for the
moment uh and this is um page 20 line 16
through Page
34 and I know there's um some people
here who want to speak on the uh
hopefully
briefly on the um manufactured home
installation
part and yeah if you can introduce
yourselves for the
record good morning Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Karen Susi I
work at shenin Capital group and I'm
here representing the New Hampshire
manufactured housing
Association morning uh my name is Eric
Coffman and I serve on the installation
Standards Board okay thank you um so
your comments on this
section yeah we just we have some
concerns about the proposed changes to
the uh the makeup of the the board um
and setting term limits on that um okay
and anything you're going to speak
please mention page and line number if
you could uh page 20 and then uh it's
basically lines
26 through well through 36
and then page
21 um lines one
through 10 okay all right thank
you right in particular if I may y
um you know we're we're going from a uh
a nine member board to an advisory three
member board um you know including
installer of the home structural
engineer dealer retailer um all being
appointed by the executive director
which was formerly um the New Hampshire
manufactured housing Association would
nominate people to this board certainly
because we have a better handle quite
frankly on members of our industry okay
um now it would be the executive
director and I guess we're trying to
find out what would be the criteria for
the executive director to choose and
nominate I'd like to do is first deal
with who the members are and deal with
how they're picked second because I may
have them come up and speak on it on
their take on it so um I know the
membership's going from 9 to
um and they're and that's generally
being done with
uh when they're moved to Advisory board
but as in the previous one we we we
didn't bring it down to brought it to
five instead so I mean if there's ones
you think are critical to be put back in
know
represent Brown yes thank you Mr chair I
think in any case a board of three I
know there must be some reason somewhere
that someone decided to go to this
number
but Boards of three um I think can be
complicated it takes one person being
out to make it to to being absent to
making it really complicated but seems
like five is a better number but it must
have been a reason someone went to three
I don't know what that was but the the
info we heard from uh the Governor's
representative was that
uh you know there's I don't know about
in this case but in general there have
been problems uh um the appointment
process is very timeconsuming and
complicated and in some cases they had
trouble finding people and and I think
they went and did this through all the
boards and it it some boards it is an
issue other boards it may not which is
why we're looking at the membership on
each of
these so they kind of did US spread did
it all the same representative mpy thank
you um is there an issue with the Quorum
and how often the board meets currently
that was one of the issues that was
addressed um the the board only meets as
necessary um so it's it's typically not
an issue we have had some issues with
getting a quorum but uh some of that I
think has more to do with the fact that
it's nine people right now I think as
representative said if we move down to
five I think that would be a much better
number and then I don't think uh getting
a quorum for any of the meetings would
be an issue okay so if we were to add
two additional
people on uh you know which which ones
suggest I don't have a problem doing
that Mr chair represent one more
question in terms of how many times did
uh the board meet in 2023 why don't we
get that from oplc and I'd like to get
an answer to this question and then
we'll move on if we can do that on who
we should add yeah um I mean in my
personal opinion I would probably say a
code official would probably be somebody
that would be good for that and then um
an owner or operator of
a a community it doesn't need to be I
don't think we need to set a each
different size
but one owner operator one it's it's
sort of the same one in the
same okay all right thank you um is
there anything else you want to say
about other parts of this and then we'll
move on to deal with uh how the me board
membership selected yeah with the the
term limits all right um on that I speak
to that it's currently I think the the
board if you were to switch to this
everybody on the board except for maybe
two people wouldn't even qualify the
board and this board has been in
existence since around I think 2005 2006
and many of those people on the board
have been on the board this entire time
and I think it's important to keep those
people on the board or let them serve
for as long as they want because of the
knowledge base they have with creating
this installation standards to begin
with um there also aren't that many
lenses in the state and I actually think
finding people if you start setting term
limits and people can't be on the board
anymore finding people that want to
serve on the board could be found to be
very difficult okay um so you excuse me
which page in line are we on with turn
he's on page 21 lines 9 through 10 nine
and
um so I guess I can see that
for um you know the people that work in
at the field so certainly the install
doer and maybe the dealer
retailer but is there a shortage of
um structural architect or engineer
maybe that is and then since we're
reducing the number of uh owner
operators I mean are there enough of
them that those that position could be
uh limited to how long they could be on
or you know would that be okay is there
an argument against
it yeah I mean I could definitely see
that those issues arising I mean it's
kind of
manufactur housing installation is kind
of a niche to begin with there aren't a
whole lot of people that just handle
this area so it's and it's not I
wouldn't call it a growing area either
it's would probably be going I would say
it's going the opposite direction with
the people that are involved interrup I
think I understand the reason for the
installer and and the dealer or retailer
having a limited number of those and so
maybe not limiting how long they can
serve but are there the same concerns
for the structural engineer and the
owner operator
members I'm not sure we could comment
about the structural engineer okay and
owner
operators I would say the same concern
um as co-ops become a bigger thing and
more communities go
louder near the mic as owner operators
and co-ops become more prevalent in the
state you're for losing the the owner
operator side of it so there are
becoming less and less of those as well
right right now there's I guess four
owner operators total on the board it
looks like two of
the small one of the yeah two of the
small one of
the
um one of 100 more and one one of 100
and less that's
two and uh okay no that's it there's
there's three right now yes so
is no that's somebody that's a co-op
that's a co-op sorry right right so um I
guess the what I'm getting that is has
there been a problem finding those
people who are owner operators of parks
today and you're saying there may be
fewer available I don't I can't it's
tough to speak that just because our
board has mostly been made up of people
that have stayed on the board for such a
long period of time that it been very
infrequent where we've need to needed to
actually find somebody new to to uh to
serve on the board okay so separate from
the membership oh representative Brown
yeah just thank you Mr chair backing up
a little maybe oplc can answer this and
maybe you can I was going to have them
up shortly
why I'm not seeing consistency in all
these rules we're looking at on term
limits seems like some of them don't
have any term limits and some of them
do yeah thank you um so any comments on
anything other than board membership and
the expiration
and then we'll have op PLC up
to no uh representative G thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so we're removing for uh
whatever a a bunch of owner operators
one of which is a Cooperative one I'm
assuming the language we replace this
with given your comment uh that that the
field if you call it I don't know what
you call it is moving the business is
moving toward a cooperative model that
you would want it to be either or that
the language be open enough that that
one member could be from a Cooperative
model or it could be from a owner
operator model that's actually a good
point if I may yeah
um there is no it's my understanding uh
that under the current uh board that
requires a Cooperative member um that
has been vacant they have not been able
to fill it
out but for future use if we leave the
language open and it can be either or
does that give the board more
flexibility as we move ahead it'd be the
appointment person F right the board
composition yeah I mean if it has a
Cooperative
now you can't really speak against it
um thank you I think I would definitely
want an owner operator on there then as
well certainly for the five right if we
well and we already talked about you
wanted a municipal Cod enforcement
officer we need an odd number so yeah um
okay let's Mr chair oh one more question
for these people that are there and so
we went from three to 5 so you added the
coding person
and I think an owner operator owner
operator instead of two we'll have one
owner operator there's actually three
because on the next page there's an
owner operator of big parks and the two
are of small Parks so and a co-op and uh
yes um Co-op is the Rocks we are talking
about correct correct and
um and we're putting building coding
code person we don't need the fire
chief I would I would say the the
building code inspector also deals with
fire code I believe and so I think
that'll cover both usually okay and I
see representative G's Point instead of
just saying owner operator there's one
small Park under 100 one larger than
100 those two making it
both either or including rocks would
make it attractive going
forward rather than coming to change
the uh statue again if you're making the
shift keeping that option open I get
that point representative Brown okay
so is there some hesitancy and some on
the part of the board some conflict
potential conflict between co-ops
and Ander owner operators where there
may be some hesitancy to say we won't
have an owner operator and only a co-op
am I reading between the lines correctly
yes you are correct okay so and follow
up follow up knowing that there's one
locally where I live one that became a
co-op I know that there was quite a bit
of um controversy there so I can
understand where the manufactured
housing authority board might not want
to have only a co-op I I think I might
understand that if I'm if that makes
sense okay and I also maybe I
misunderstood but I thought I heard two
answers to a question that were
different um is there currently I
thought somebody said that the co-op
position was vacant M yeah that's
correct okay all right okay thank you if
you could Mr chair because there's only
10% co-op in New Hampshire versus 90% of
a mobile park in Vermont is co-ops well
I have to say there's there's 147
resident-owned communities in the state
that far out numbers the privately owned
in the state so it's okay uh we could if
you could take a seat and have the folks
from oplc come
up
so uh my first question may be more of a
policy one if you don't don't have an
answer that's fine and that is um around
the owner operator versus Co-op members
if we're not going to have both I mean I
is there anything you can say on that I
think that um as it came up we don't
have a pref I think the change that um
was proposed uh through the governor's
office was because that position has
never been filled so that which one the
co Cooperative one as was mentioned it's
vacant now but it has never been um
filled as a board member and to
represent M's point I if we put it as um
owner operator or Co-op that wouldn't
pres wouldn't cause a problem and if we
if there's a move in the future as there
might be to you know predominantly Co-op
at some point then that would
offer the flexibility does that seem
reasonable that's how I would see it as
well yes okay oh question to repr M yeah
thank you Ma Mr chair So currently there
are four members so we're cutting down
to two from the community which is the
housing the man owner or Co-op it used
to be four before we're cutting down to
with an or with an or so it' be one or
the other but that's still one member
yeah oh
so I'm completely off now uh line three
on page 21 line one on page
21 and
35 yeah uh on page 20 right what we're
proposing is to add back in two
positions correct one of them is line is
Page 21 5 which is a municipal building
code official MH and then the other one
is um you know one position which would
either be um an owner operator of a
manufactured housing park
or um a member of a Cooperative
manufactured housing oh no I yeah and
and without a without a a lot limit
right right no no no size limits to any
so can I ask for a clarification on page
20 30 uh line 33 one dealer or
retailer is not a owner of the
park correct it's a dealer or retailer
of the manufactured hous housing so H so
what should end up with is one installer
one dealer retailer one um either owner
operator or member of a
co-op and um the uh the code enforcement
person and that's what we would have so
you'd have
one um right we keep
ABC yeah and I I would have a problem
with that because the consumer in terms
of whether Co-op or um manufacturing
Park is only has one seat at the board
whereas the provider like if you put in
that the structural engineer we need uh
the
dealer and
installer these are the provider of
these mot you know so they have a much
large are you following me yeah I the
clarification as I'm thinking about it
and hearing you talk is that the
difference in this board is that they do
not have a public member like many of
our other boards do it is the um the
like Cooperative or owner members
someone that's a owner operator so
that's that's I think what it could be
sort of related to correct I you you hit
the point so I want to make sure the
public member is the consumer and we
want to have a good representation both
uh owner of a park also the Cooperative
so there's more um voice equal voice so
I I see I understand the the concern um
so I see two ways of dealing with it one
is um to stay at five and we would have
to drop either an installer or the
dealer or retailer or say it would be an
installer or a dealer or
retailer um so that's an option and then
and then add
um add a second um two members who are
owner operators or or members of Co-op I
me that's one way to go the other way
we' have to add because we have to stay
odd we'd have to add two and so we you
know then we could add I
suppose um but then you'd have a public
member who is a resident of the home is
different than an owner operator right
it is different I was just trying to say
that this board is is unique in the fact
that it doesn't have a public member so
I think because of the uniqueness of the
um profession and the owner operator or
cooperative
piece of it trying to get the voice to
be more specific to the actual
profession is why we wouldn't see that
there so that's but I was just trying to
say that's why there's a little bit of
that uniqueness here but where that
piece comes in I thought we heard
earlier though that and from what I've
seen in bill that uh for the advisory
boards generally the public member is
not included correct so but there also
is it one currently that's sort of my
point right residents of trailer parks
have never had a voice and we had a
hearing if you all remember where the
residents were quite concerned about not
having a voice and about the impact on
their lives because these are their
homes exact Mr Cherry if I can just that
was my concern I understand um you have
something represent no I was going to
say something political incorrect no
no um what about if we added two more
and make this a board of seven and we
add two to the either or
um um add to or make it
to make make the one two that's an owner
operator or Corp keep the or language in
there but have two positions under that
category and then add a public member
who is a
resident of one of these Parks or
cooperatives well then they couldn't
well if they're a member of The
Cooperative if they're in living in the
Cooperative they're they're an owner
that's kind of what a co-op is so that's
what I'm asking what does that mean
owner you like to come up and to the mic
and provide some I was going to get you
before we decided
yeah so first of all before you get up
um is there do you see any problem
adding a member from the llc's
functional point of view adding a member
who is a
um a resident I guess in a park but not
a
co-op well no we no we're adding two we
can do with that adding to right if you
want to come up and uh you can help
together don't enough to right that is
an issue well but then but we're taking
out
of right but they could there could be
concerns about if they get overboarding
the
I all right um every board that's five
deal with this yeah I don't yeah husand
to go beyond five but representative
Brown so uh correct me if I'm wrong
which could very well be the
case when a person is a resident they
buy a mobile home in a
park they should understand what their
rights
are and how the process works so to come
here later and say I don't have a voice
don't they already know what their voice
is when they buy their mobile
home so I think we might be conflating
here um well I'm touching on what these
guy said about residents not having a
voice oh boy this this could be a whole
other we don't want to go there well I
just not sure if it it's up to the chair
as well it's relevant to this situation
well it looks like people are are you
know questioning so if you can do
something briefly yeah okay so you have
um privately owned communities and you
have resident owned communities okay I
represent the privately owned
communities what do you mean by
privately owned communities so a
business owns the park correct not the
people living in it correct in the
resident-owned communities the residents
own the parks is that what's meant by
Co-op yes okay
okay did you need anything further
just a fine yeah distinction
is in a resident own they own the land
also the well well to clarify it's Wes
one I mean they may own their mobile
home but the qu I I'm assuming the
company owns owns the land exactly
that's the distinction between the rock
pay your pay to keep your part your
mobile home there like an
association well that's a co-op
more of these that aren
in right people just own them right
right well if they if they own the land
and they own the mobile home and it's
one one on a piece of land then none of
this applies representing well they're
they're not affected by this I don't
think okay they they are so if I may
just further clarify yeah when we're
discussing installing manufactured homes
yeah this was brought into place back in
200 5 when HUD the federal government
said there are too many problems these
these homes are not being installed
properly either they're falling off the
foundations you you know you've got in
the the Midwest and on the the eastern
coast they have hurricanes we need to do
something to ensure that these homes are
installed correctly so HUD said either
you know you follow our standards or
state of New Hampshire you come up with
your own and so the state of New
Hampshire did that now this is only
about making sure that a home is
installed properly whether it's on a
private piece of property whether it's
in a resident-owned community or whether
or not it's in a private park so when I
hear you talking about whether or not
the voice of a resident in a resident
owned Community is heard with regard to
installing homes of which they do not
install I'm not sure why we would have
that concern in this particular issue
follow up Mr chair
represent Co thank you so help me
understand what and maybe this is an
oplc but I think you guys can answer
this what are there any issues that the
board currently or historically has
handled the impact the
residents when you hear complaints and
complaints it's been a long it's been a
long time it's been a long time since
we've heard and issue um there are very
few issues because the program works
very well um
and people tend to do a good job of
installing these homes so I take back my
comment because clearly it must have
been a different board or some complaint
happening it had to do with residents
and financing and all of that and you
don't handle that just is purely
installation the installation of the
home on the
site thank you Mr chair thank you for
clarifying that
installing and build
retailer code enforcement that is to
establish the home once the park is once
the home is
established running of it whether the
financing comes from HUD or private or
that is not the preview of this board
but do the residents have a way to get
to any complaints after after I think
that's actually off topic because if
this board isn't dealing with it then
it's not put to this bill and we're
running late briefly yeah well I just
have to make sure everyone understands
under the the board and also somehow
with the oplc with all the changes that
are going on part of HUD in order to be
compliant with cud you had HUD you had
to make sure that you maintained a
dispute resolution program under the
installers board so that the
manufacturer the installer and the
retailer couldn't each point their
finger and say it's their fault not ours
so it pulled everyone to the table so
that's what you're talking about correct
Mr well we've got the installer we've
got the retailer and we've got um either
somebody who owns the park or at least
we're proposing um somebody who's a
member of One the co-op thing represent
Brown um so who
C who can make a complaint
who legitimately can make a complaint so
could a a an individual resident that
had a play home installed they could
complain to the board it was installed
improperly that is correct so there is a
little piece where individual residents
can come to the board okay yes and
that's up to a up to a year after the
home's been sold so I I have a question
for um the lady sitting uh to the back
are you here to speak on this or which
which item are
you okay thank you just want to make
sure sure we're not ignoring somebody on
this one
[Music]
um yes if you have so if we have to
address that the complaints are
somewhere there either oplc takes it or
the board takes it there has to be a
channel because that's the voice of the
consumer holding something that may not
be satisfactory that was given to them
right okay and I'm going to actually
asked that can we get oplc back up here
thank you musical chairs do you think do
you think you would ever get a member of
the public to sit thank you and I this
is why we love working with our uh
associations as well because when we
have 57 boards she very eloquently
articulated that uh so thank you because
that's the the corrects of it yeah
so with it you know if it moves to
Advisory board or maybe even what we did
last year it may already be set um what
would how would complaints be hand
handled they would still be processed
through the office through what was done
last year with 655 so it's consistent as
any other board for those complaints and
as mentioned with the HUD requirement we
are working with the board to uh update
their rules so that way their rules
point to that current process which is
in compliance with the HUD process for
the complaints and that's the complaints
about the installations that is not the
complaints about um the parks or the you
know the after um that was repealed last
year that complaint board was repealed
last year and now is with doj through um
any Consumer complaint prot consumer
protections correct
um okay and would you know what's going
on to the rulem and all that would that
be significantly affected by moving to
an advisory report or would it um what
we're seeing with the installers board
is that they rules have been expired um
there have been a couple of pieces to
that one of them was that they did meet
six times last year I'm not sure exactly
um what delayed the rules from being uh
reopt prior to their expiration uh this
would just allow if we went to advisory
the members who were attending or
available I believe there were a couple
meetings where people were there but we
didn't have Quorum so there wasn't able
to be any votes if they were advisory um
with their subject matter expertise we
would be able to move forward in a more
timely fashion okay all right uh
representative gold thank you Mr chair I
have a question regarding the uh concern
that was brought up on um making the
change from the board making the
appointments to oplc making the
appointments can we add language in here
that the board will nominate to to the
executive director member those
positions right that was the next thing
I wanted to get to was yeah
uh I mean how would the uh oplc actually
pick people and um you could we leave in
some language that it's nominated but
maybe somehow confirmed or whatever by
the executive
director we talk about this last week um
I I think one of
the you can decide obviously uh one of
the concerns about the nomination and
we've had some conversations over the
past few months is how it's currently
listed by being need to by needing to be
nominated by specific associations we
have gotten a few applications for board
members that haven't come that route and
so we've had to then stop it or ask them
to get nominated from another agency and
so it has not it has um delayed some of
those processes um and although we have
board members who have been a part of
this board for a very long time many of
them are in hold over status as well um
so I think there could potentially be
language and we could look at that if if
um Doug is willing to work with me on
that uh and maybe even the association
to say what would that language look
like so that way it's not each position
being nominated by a certain Association
but maybe a more generalized nomination
and definition process right yeah
because I wouldn't be comfortable
requiring people to be member of a
particular Association who serve on the
board that's problematic followup
representative maputi
thank you Mr chair I was just going to
say it's not either or the board
professional board Advisory board can
nominate or have the option to do that
and oplc also go look for it so finally
making the decision what's best for the
industry would come up I would assume
oplc is going to get ideas on who to put
on there from places like just going to
anybody can make a recommendation to us
so if we left it as executive
director it could come from wherever it
can come from wherever and and I'd
actually be yeah but with just to follow
up with that one just with that I'm just
saying giving the board and voice also
and not cutting them completely because
we have to work with them right
represent Co you it okay all right
um
so yeah we need
to oh the only other question I have had
is um uh do oplc have any comment on the
um the language that they can't serve
more than two full terms there were
concerns raised that there may not be
enough people available to serve and if
you start doing that we could change the
threeyear term limit we could add
consecutive because right now it says
two full terms we could add the word
consecutive there so that somebody could
serve to take some time off come back I
there's a couple of options but I don't
think we have strong opinions on that
okay
and would it be a problem we just took
that language out because right is there
well right now there is apparently is
not a limit on how many
it Mike sorry that's my understanding as
well um it it might be helpful to leave
something in there so that way we don't
get in a place where we have someone
who is not responsive and we're unable
to appoint another person because
they're still in their term so I think
there needs to be some sort of language
um but that can allow for reapplying um
or
reappointment re Brown thank you Mr
chair I'm just going to follow up again
am am I wrong in Remembering we don't
have term limits on all these advisory
boards or am I remembering too many
pieces of too many bills in the last
weeks Mr chair the only one I remember U
representative manip Puchi just came up
with uh reminded me was the judicial
appeals board the other day there were
no term limits but normally I've seen
term limits on all board appointments
and the concern when you take away term
limits is you never know you might get
somebody in the on a board that and and
just even the tendency becomes it
becomes very insula or as uh my
colleague to my left likes to say Guild
like and um and it just ensures some
diversity but I think we could add a
year to the the term go from a
three-year term to a four-year term two
consecutive terms is eight years by then
you'd think the board could find a
replacement and I um as I'm looking at
some of our other advisory boards it
does have term limits but I do think
that word consecutive is an important
one um because like Doug um indicated
that allows for someone to take a break
and then come back um onto the board
whereas the way it's written right now
is that that once you're done you're
done okay uh R Brown do you have
not thank you Mr chair yes I was just
going to
say this this leaves you no option if
you can't find anybody to fill
it but the person that's there would be
willing to be nominated but you can't
find another person a term limit shuts
that down but that's that's the nature
of how that works I guess my
understanding is that they are able to
stay in holdover status I don't know the
reference uh to the statute but that if
there is no one to fill that and they
want to stay in that they can stay in
that holdover status until someone else
applies for that position perect thank
you right and and also as advisory
getting a reaching quum is less critical
for immediate things that are needed
okay um so
like to make some motions we need to
move on um as far as the issue of
nominated by who and
whatever I would actually like to leave
it like it is in the bill where it's um
it's left up to the executive director
but I mean the executive director is not
going to have I doubt is going to have
her Pals in there to St stack the board
but they're going to have to get
nominated you know suggestions from
someplace and my guess is um that would
be you know at least partly the
Hampshire manufacturer Housing
Association so um I'd like to make a
motion to um to
leave the board appointment the same not
I'm talking about membership of the
board but how they're
appointed nominated or no appointed um
okay yeah y right
um keep keep keep what's in the
bill um I would have a problem problem
worde my concern would be that we are
shifting from Authority from one to
another and not helping with making a
sustainable change that's my you know I
mean if we put it in the Statue it's
fine now director Courtney is here she
understands what it is what our intent
is what the you know discussion if there
is a change at that
level if nothing in the statute says
this is how it was done or this was the
intention there's a nomination you can
take you know it's easier not to go back
to a referral source to say hey we don't
have to so let's I've got the motion on
the floor somebody want to Second it and
then we can nobody wants second it it'll
fail which is fine okay which I'm okay
with all right um so further discussion
I I mean it does limit who they can be
it's got to be some installer
manufactured housing and we're doing the
similar thing I mean he's got a a
structural
engineer um with at least five worked in
the state for at least five years and
similarly uh if we decide to put back in
the building code official that is
nominated by them
I don't know about that actually whether
the U building official association
should be nominating
the uh code enforcement person that Mr
chair I'm okay with how the members are
selected it's just saying giving the
association an input into nominating
process it doesn't have to say it
doesn't have to say they have to accept
it but at least there's a the oplc will
refer to it all right it's clear I think
clear we're going to have to meet again
yeah Mr chair um I just want to say on
page 21 line 29 it does say the duties
of the executive director in
consultation with The Advisory Board
shall be and then it goes into um does
that include the uhin people to the
board um so I I believe it may uh in
consultation with my legal counsel uh
also when we're looking at some of our
other Advisory Board uh medical imaging
has language in there that Under The
Advisory board established that says The
Advisory Board shall advise the
executive director regarding the
Implement implementation of this chapter
so it's specific to the structure of The
Advisory Board and so it states that so
we I can um email that over or you can
look at that reference but that might be
something there is already statutory
language for other advisory boards okay
so that would um that might change the
language on uh page 21
line9 shell is a better thing than
may it says in consultation uh sh yeah
I'm okay with that as long as there is
shell not me okay so um yes chair on
page 20 line
27 it says that these people will be
appointed by
the executive director of The Office of
professional lur and certification if we
insert in consultation with The Advisory
board right there I think we cover it
okay all right um so shall consult so
let's go that would be page 20 line 28
because I will not remember any of this
but um I'll in consult in consultation
with The Advisory board if you just go
back to page 21 line 29 shall
be you know that shell I think there's a
shell on the end there well the duty
shall be yeah but this would make it
very clear that the appointment would be
in consultation
yeah okay so I
will um I will amend my
motion to include that change so we'll
add in consultation with The Advisory
board on on page 20
uh line 28 or 27 and
28 I will second it Mr chair well okay
so we already we have a motion I'm just
amending the motion if if representative
Bailey's okay with that change since he
was the
seconder okay so we'll just keep the
original motion with that change all
right um all in so what we're voting
on is basically to accept the whole
installer board part it'll become an
Advisory Board
um we can change the um as the the
membership as we discussed which would
be what's that from 9 to5 we'd have a
owner operator or Co-op one member and
we would add back in the code
enforcement
person and
um and then uh the changes to the
language change from three to four years
term and and to add a consecutive full
term so that people could come back
on um and that's so that that's what the
motion is so everyone in favor oh you
have more discussion Y no well it is
it's a comment I think just kind of for
the record I think that making the
nominating process uh
taking it maybe solely out of the hands
of of the executive director is is a
good thing
because not myself but there are there
are a number of people that always
question what government is doing
regardless of how how good of a job
they're doing having worked there for 30
years I know how that works and and it's
people will question it sometimes no
matter what so I think that adding this
in to have consultation with the board
on nominations will make
that
process the perception of that to be
more transparent okay thank you Mr uh
okay rep that's I second it that's
exactly was my point Thank you very good
so um the motion is as described all in
favor I anyone
opposed all right thank you so we have
completed the
housing manufactured housing
installation section
on to massage therapist page 25
24 line 35 26 line 3 one and let me get
to that and OPC can stay up there Mr
chair this is one of the boards that
they asked correct to go on to it should
be an easier transition because actually
I just got a good uh suggestion and that
is since we have someone here
uh wiffy Council why don't we move to
that yes uh thank you for that so that's
page
line
32 let me get find it
here um we'll leave oplc up there for
the
moment so that's there
through
[Music]
um page 29 line 23 so there's all this
stuff and okay so if we go
um and if we can if you need to have a
discussion we can leave time for it but
otherwise
um representative G and Bailey is there
something we need to hear or no we were
just at the one yes I was looking for
the end page oh the end page on that one
I believe is page 26 line 31 unless I
messed
upid oh the Midwifery is I think page 29
line 23 it
is okay all right
so going through this as usual with
these things there makes it
advisory um and actually quick question
on the last one oplc how many of these
uh installers are there because we get
into the question of one of the
arguments for Advisory Board is there's
but then we'll go to the same question
then for Midwife I don't have that data
but I can get that for you is it fairly
small you think yes okay um and we also
heard testimony they can't find members
of the board because there aren't enough
people in the profession LIC okay so now
we're on same question question actually
for the Midwifery um how
many
huh no no the installation of what they
work on is a different process but but
um it's a growing profession what it's
yeah that's not a licensed profession at
all um I can speak from family anyway um
so how many licensed midwives are there
about it's around
30 okay thank you no I just wanted to
ask the same question
and I'm my job is to really straight man
it's an ugly job but somebody's got to
do it um all right so
um let me get back here so Mr chair
before we go any that uh the to reduce
Workforce barrier those things that
changed right I sent you the email out
where I'd have them do it everywhere I
mean I I called all the places so we're
going to do that and and the other
General changes um that we agreed on so
I'm just going to briefly talk to this
so there's the what the sections are so
there's the making advisory which uh
given the small number of midwives I
think is important um then changes to
the advisory Council which we'll need to
go
through and um the rest of it is mostly
I think the standard um moving to a
Advisory Board and then there's a couple
other things like on page 28 line line
um 22 is taking out the board having fee
setting Authority which last year we
moved to oplc anyway and that needs to
be
done and um the rest of it is
um it basically part of making Advisory
Board
um
so if we actually probably the best for
when unless oplc has got some overall
comments then like to have the uh person
here is going
to who came to speak come up and uh
introduce herself
input hi thank you for hearing me today
I'm Sher you get close to the mic please
we can pull the whole thing forward if
it's easier yep I'm Sher Stevens I'm in
New Hampshire certified midwife and we
have 33 um midwives currently um
certified and three
pending as what and three pending oh
three pending yeah three in the
process okay so anything else you'd like
to say yeah so my concern is um first of
all putting us into a Advisory Board in
general because I know we are a small U
population and we're a small board um
but we do deal with um
maternity care we take care of pregnant
people and we deliver babies and we
think this is a public health issue to
have an executive director or somebody
other than the experts in the field
regulating our board and this takes away
our ability for rul making and and um
qualifications as I spoke to yesterday
as well as you know we understand oplc
we absolutely 100% behind them doing the
administrative work doing the um running
the running the board meetings um
certification process and the
disciplinary process we understand
that's happening and we're we're okay
with that we've been wanting support for
for many many years we're really happy
for that um and but in terms of moving
away from having somebody else telling
this profession um you know what our
qualifications are and how we practice
as a concern argue that that's a
mischaracterization it's it is required
in here on for all of the advisor boards
that they have to do it executive
director has to do it in consultation
with the board um and if they do
something wacky anyway then it's still
got to go through the rules you know
541a process of of uh public comment and
ultimately you know you tell jail Jael
car that they've done something insane
uh but but there's a general uh feeling
from legal liability issues that any any
board with uh fewer than 200 licensed
people really should become an Advisory
Board and midwy one is pretty extreme in
that regard so from a
um Li not just liability but I mean you
know is it right and ethical for Market
participants when you have that small
number uh to actually regulate direct
and have direct final control over the
rest of the market participants and I
think there's a a general feeling that
that is not the case and that that's not
appropriate
and and subject to leaves the state and
the board subject to uh legal action if
uh some somebody doesn't like the
outcome so and we we had a we spent an
hour or plus dealing with that at the
beginning of all these hearings so and I
apologize I wasn't here that hearing um
so the other part is that you have it
down to um two midwives and one
physician so there's a big difference
between a pediatrician and obstetrician
One deals with with um pregnant women
when deals with the baby they are not
the same expertise in in any shape or
form and so I know that they the current
um ones that serve on the board have a
real issue with that and the two
midwives we would when we had done going
back to hb2 and had looked at this we
had asked for um three midwives and two
Physicians we do have a public member
which we value very much um I could
consider two midwives a public member
and the two Physicians we had I think
they had wanted to put it to five so
that there's a um you know a more
majority rule as opposed to six six has
been working great we've been having um
monthly meetings we have Quorum we have
a plenty of people that have been
willing to serve and serve well we are
always um you know whatever these
Physicians are it says expertise with um
midw free that could be friendly or not
there are midw uh there are Physicians
out there that are not friendly to to
our profession and so we are very um
acutely aware of that and in in our
profession as a whole and having an
advisory committee and having this go
down to what we were we were told and
what we understand is advisory committee
is um they they ask the um board The
Advisory board our expert opinion but
they can also just not do it you know
and that we would hope in good faith
that is that is true and and like um the
pres was saying director Courtney has
been you know supportive and wonderful
and if she leaves and we get somebody in
that doesn't like midwe free we're out
they can just stop our profession you I
and it has happened in other states
right and I okay so I I think going to
uh Advisory Board is something that we
need to do uh given the small number of
midwives so we've covered that however
we're definitely open to changing the
membership from what this bill
proposes and so the question is if you
Mr chair I have a quick question for let
me let me finish what I'm saying
please um so my we'll get to that my
question is um you mentioned three
midwives and two Physicians if we went
that route um would you would just be
two Physicians or or back to one
obstetrician one pediatrician one
obstetrician one pediatrician okay and
in generally The Advisory boards don't
have public members and so that would
there would be a five member board okay
represent
mapy quick question to the midv do you
include both nurse midv as well as Doula
midv or just Doula midy Dua and midwife
Frey it is not du Midwife it's a New
Hampshire certified
midwife so there's certified nurse
midwives under the nursing board okay
and then certified um New Hampshire
certified midwives we conduct prenatal
care the deliveries on our own
postpartum care on our own and one more
followup this is all home birds do you
also participate in the hospital births
we do not participate in hospital births
we do participate in um birth center
births birthing centers birthing centers
there are four of them in the state
currently okay thank you douas are a
different
profession uh representative Brown thank
you Mr
chair um I I know you mentioned this
that we talked about this earlier but so
the Board of Medicine is not becoming an
Advisory board right am I right in that
what carry on
okay the Board of Medicine is not
becoming an Advisory
Board
and I'm not sure what the reason for
that is
if safety no there the issue the issue
is different it's there are a lot of
physicians in the state and you don't
have the problem where a group of Market
participants um um are are regulating
you know are making it are regulating a
small community of licensed people if
you have I mean the current membership
you got six you got one fifth of all
practicing midwives on the board which
means they're deciding they presumably
most of them know each other they're
deciding you know complaints and who can
get license to this small group of
people and that's a serious conflict of
interest where with the doctors there's
many more doctors and so why you can
argue it's not a nonissue but it is
dramatically less of an issue and and
then I mean the complaints can are
different we do not handle the
complaints currently oplc has taken that
over so that that is separated separated
from us can somebody from oplc get up um
there are very few complaints there's
been one or two over over the 30 years
oh okay that's great um I I guess my
question on that is if there were a
complaint I know the investigation and
and that is handled by oplc but um as
far as making a decision on whether or
not it's valid is they would they be
Consulting with the board now and also
is what's the case if it's advisory yes
even if it's advisory it would still go
to the board um for review and subject
matter expertise if needed um but if
there was an inability to have a quorum
or to get to that place then the um
statutory Authority still rests on opl
and so we would be able to move forward
with that if it's an Advisory Board
correct but at a regulatory board does
the board basically make the final
decision on it oplc would do the
investigation and present maybe uh Doug
can pushing me out of the way I know we
need three seats up there maybe I don't
so we receive the complaint we do an
investigation we don't need any
authority to the board then we bring
that to the board with a recommendation
but the board decides whether or not to
move forward with dis discipline or
dismiss the case if they move forward
with discipline the board is the finder
of fact so they kind of say we think
this happened we think this happened and
oplc steps in on kind of the legal side
running the hearing hearing officers
answering you know calling balls and
Strikes so today with this uh regulatory
board we solv the problem where members
of this very small group of people is
making decisions for a a relatively
small number of members in their
profession and that's problematic
correct okay thank you represent man py
thank you uh Mr chair another quick
question for the midv is
this spread ACR obviously it's spread
across the state is this addressing the
pockets of rural Pockets where the
access to the hospital or access to
health care for pregnant women is
addressed we are very much concerned
about that in the closing of the the
different birthing hospitals um they are
midwives located in all areas of the
state there's probably one in the North
Country so that is an issue um but that
again getting more Midwife into the
state and and more midwives practicing
is our goal and we are looking at um
being able to support the doctors and
the clinics and things like that with
our care to be able to reach out to the
rural pockets and we do because we are
experts in home care and we can go and
do home visits you know and I've
suggested um that we make a partnership
where we could we could easily do a
prenal visit or doing a um blood
pressure or something like that and then
reporting back to the doctor if that was
their highrisk pa okay I mean this is
really not the bill please we need to
stop that because we actually have a
chance of getting done today other than
approving the final Amendment so I'd
like to make a motion um which is to
adopt a section on
Midwifery um with the
change of the membership of the board um
change ing it to three midwives and I
think there's a def yeah certified yep
and 1 OB and we'll put back in the 1 OB
and the one pediatrician with expertise
with the yes the current language that's
in there with the with this uh pertinent
experience I just leave take the current
language and put it back in for those
two and
U so you're making the change on line 8
off page 27 in instead of six going to
five members right there'd be a number
of changes it would go to Five members
um the number of midwives would go to
three rather than two and we would put
back in on lines uh 16 through 18 or 16
through 19 the um the doctors with the
appropriate suest
uh represent well first of all I I put
the motion on somebody want to Second it
then we can have discussion okay fine
procedural all right representative
Brown yeah I I don't know if it's listed
in duy somewhere else but do we want to
include as we did in the last one so now
on page 27 line 10 midwy Council
appointed by the executive director in
consultation with the board is what we
did last time right so you're looking at
line 10 after the
Bold okay so that's page 27
line
10 um what did we say with consultation
of the advisory repard whatever you said
in the last one shall shall consult no
no that's that's not how that no the
shall came after the in consultation on
the last but but it could be the
exective I mean I'm okay with that but
we can uh Doug if you can get up here if
we just say the executive director of
The Office of professional license and
certification in consultation with the
board um and we're talking about page 27
line 10 line 10 I think that creates a
requirement re to work with the that's
what I was thinking it's it's not a May
so that's something we you're saying you
we do this we will do this even without
the word shall it's kind
of um I'm fine with that so I will I
will um thank you update my motion to
include that and if representative Brown
the second or agrees with that I agree
with that all right fine
so that's the motion to adopt this
section with the change of adding that
language that they have to consult on
the appointments three midwives one ob
one pediatrician raising the total to
five um as long as that is there I'm
fine with okay um all in favor I all
opposed okay that's unanimous so and
just a procedural thing when I'm going
to do like I did before I'm going to
take the list of all the changes I will
update it with this stuff and I'll send
it out to people and look at it I'll try
and you know do it accurately and that
what we may do um at a future hearing is
throw this one at the top and get a a
formal vote on approving the whole thing
so okay um we're done with the Midwife
one thank
you what's that no thank thank you thank
you though
yes I mean you can still uh submit
written comment to fully DNA if you'd
like
so okay uh let's go back to combining uh
The Advisory Board which is already an
Advisory Board massage therapist and the
board of reflexology page 24 line 35
through 26 l31
yes
um Mr chair this is the one which has
more members it's more than 200 correct
and they ask to be done yeah if oplc can
going give an introduction to what's
going on with
this so massage is already an Advisory
Board they do have more members but the
reflexology um and structural Integrity
in Asian Body Works does not and so they
are looking to merge they're about how
many uh I will get that for you and just
so you know um for home
installers uh we H currently have 64
licensed home installers oh jeez okay so
that's well under the the 200
thing okay um so the issue on the board
side I the number of licensed people's
reflexology and we can fix that by
merging them with which page um okay so
this is starting on page 24 near the
bottom at line
35 through line page
26 um 31 31 right thank
you
and
and so if you so you said this request
came from the board of reflexology or
where did it okay I'm not sure if it
came from the board but I know I we have
not heard any opposition on this I think
we've even had conversations with them
and they agree with the change okay but
conversations right and that's my
recollection Mr chair right and it looks
like and there was no concern about the
membership of the board or anything else
raised a quick question for oplc even
though it is more than 200 members it's
close to three or
400 combining would that make a
difference for advisory or
statutary well it's already advisory
both of them already advisory so that's
not an issue for us question no one is
advisory and one does not have a is that
true I think they're both advisory both
both advisory that's we're just merging
what the analysis um says anyway and
already is don't have to worry about
that right I
mean I'm going to make a motion and then
we can have discussion afterwards and
that is to adopt or to keep keep this
section as
is okay this is the section on the
merger of these two boards which is Page
20 uh
sorry it start what I just said yeah it
starts at look 24 line 35 okay I'll put
that on page 24 line
35 page 26 L 31 line 31 yeah that's the
motion to keep that as
is um I think you
know and issue I mean how I know she's
looking up how many reflexologists but
have been problems 21 21 oh jeez and uh
so uh even advisory so there have been
problems just getting people to serve on
that board or has that not been a
problem um correct we now have we do
have three members on that advisory on
that board now um but it has been about
trying to find times when they can meet
and having Quorum and again the issue of
the you know three members and 21 active
licenses even though they're advisory
there's still issues with that right
okay um do I have a second for that
motion yes uh one more question it sure
Asian Arts is part of reflexology
[Music]
or Asian body Arts reflexology massage
there are three different licensed
profession so there's currently the
board of massage and then there is the
board of
reflexology um I want to get the
structural integr integrators and Asian
Bodywork that is one board the that
those three license types and in that
board there's 21
lenses okay thank you so any further
discussion before we move to vote
represent Brown yes thank you um I don't
see anywhere in here the similar
language
to um having the executive director do
the
appointments seems to be missing in
consult even the regardless of yeah the
in consultation unless I just I'm
missing it yeah where is the appointment
stuff it's usually in with the the the
the the the structure of the board
itself it is on page 25 line 21 members
shall be appointed oh sorry it just
that's yeah and you're hitting my point
exactly it just says they shall be
appointed
24 yeah that's P page 25 line 24 the
board shall advise the executive
director regarding the implementation of
this chapter and then up above on line
18 it says the executive director shall
establish The Advisory Board and so that
gives some of this wouldn't be bolded
because it's existing existing so that
gives her the authority to make the
appointments and and it requires that
she do that with uh the advice of the
board it's saying the same thing in a
circular fashion doing it differently
yeah the word shall is there so there is
a consultation so a lot of this language
was lifted from existing statute we
inconsistencies just as long as everyone
of the s that that's is what that means
right and ultimately the courts but well
right so do we have to have any further
discussion or can we move yeah it's
double negative triple negative makes it
positive I think you're right okay all
all in favor of doing this keeping it as
is anyone
opposed alrighty so we are
done with the merge of these two boards
we only
have system in lers well we have the
septic system and then we've got the
board of examiners of uh nursing home
administrators so um let's do septic
system
next how about the eight the nursing
home that's a small I just said I just
said that's another yeah that's a small
one right I mean we don't have anybody
here to speak on either one that's a
quick one um yeah um that that's the
board you just repealed in no no that
was nine oh Board of registration of
medical technicians and we already okay
agreed the subcommittee agreed to pull
that out the ones that I think are left
are on the analysis seven and eight the
septic system evaluators turned them
into advisory and the same thing for the
board of examiners of nursing home
administrators that's what I have to so
unless there's a reason to take them in
a different order I was going to take
them in order here and that would be the
septic system I don't know if there's a
reason but the nursing home
administrators was at the request of the
board okay let's do that one first that
six
it and that goes
through uh so this is a nurse
Jing
home and that is um page
34 line six through
Page
39 line six as well okay um if you can
just give an overview of of what's going
on here and who was okay with it or not
um So currently we have 155 active Li
licensed nursing home administrators in
the State uh the board has uh been
supportive of moving to an Advisory
Board um they are able to provide
insight and support they do attend their
meetings regularly but I believe they
understand the um change to be advisory
would be helpful in that they are a
small board uh and very involved with
each other and all of the
lienes okay and they didn't have a
problem with uh the proposed board
membership going down to three not that
we've heard no okay so they they are
okay with three
Bailey all go up to the mic are there
are there only 155 nursing homes in the
or I don't know the answer to that um I
think some of the LI some of the nursing
homes have fall under more than one
administrator so um like larger
corporations like genesis might have a
nursing home administrator that covers
three or four different locations um but
this is one of those boards where DHHS
does the licensing of the facilities we
license the
profession thank you okay 10 County and
rest of it private okay so um I'll do it
I'll make a motion to
um to keep de this as
bill and I need a
second second okay thank
you and any further um discussion before
we go to a vote um Brown I'm just trying
to follow up on the appointment piece
again the nomination and appointment
piece that's all because a lot of that
was
stricken on page 3 4 line
2122 appointed by the executive
director
um it it's the same language like the
previous one page 34 where uh
line 15 to 18 the executive director
shall cons consult with The Advisory
Board to establishing
established that was
[Music]
uh and and that got left in that gener
General language right it did yeah and
the stuff the workforce barrier stuff I
took out long right okay thank you
that's good okay um any further
discussion we can move to a
vote all right all in favor of uh
keeping the section as it is in the bill
I anyone opposed oh great five to zero
all right in that case we have one
more and we get to deal with uh sewage
no septic evaluators so that is let make
notes and that's
um page
29 line
24 through Page
34 line
five um let me get to the start of that
and if you can give kind of any
introduction to what what the deal is
how mean how many of them there are what
was behind
this I believe this comes down to the
numbers again there's about
135 um LIC licensed septic system
evaluators uh which has also and we've
also seen some Quorum issues uh with
this board and so this will assist in uh
those meetings being able
to uh happen without uh uh Quorum so in
2023 they had six meetings uh scheduled
and three of them were cancelled um in
2022 there were five meetings SCH
scheduled and two of those canceled so
in 2022 there were only three meetings
in 2023 there were three meetings as
well um so this will assist in the the
operations and Licensing of these Prof
this profession yes has there been much
in the way of complaints they've had to
deal with
or I don't have those numbers but I
could gather that information that's all
right any any questions from the
committee you already asked one so how
does the complaint now flow
through it's the same as uh all of the
other board processes so the complaint
comes through the office it is reviewed
and investigated uh by the office that
is then brought to the board um to
decide the next steps um and process
like the other regulatory boards the
statutory ones not advisory regulatory
yeah uh re of course I noticed it's
septic system evaluators as opposed to
installers does that imply it's for
existing septic systems or somehow or is
are the evaluators the ones that approve
plans for what do they do actually I
guess I'm looking it
up you should know this if I may I
should know this the board of septic
system evaluators is established to set
minimum standards and guidelines to
ensure that licensed evaluators have a
level of knowledge well yeah that's kind
of what evaluating student hang on a
so but this is more informational it
doesn't say that in here unless we need
an answer on this I I'd like to move
just curious somebody want to make a
motion on this well I'll make a motion
it could certainly be that I if you have
a question about a septic system you
have someone come in to assess its
condition maybe that's an a Valu I'm
guessing that I mean I will say I just
La last year spent a ton of money
replacing my septic system and uh we had
to get uh plans drawn up and somebody
had who was licensed I guess had to
approve the plans and I'm wondering if
that's that person I believe that's the
process trying to read this and life
experience I believe that you have
someone who does the plans and installs
it but then you have to have someone
come out like a building code insector
something the surveyor has to come out
they provide input to the engineer the
engineer draws the plans and then
there's somebody that has to approve
those plans and town the building
inspector gets involved too ours does Mr
chair yeah my husband was a licensed
septic and we just had this discussion
the other night so I apologize I missed
your whole conversation but I can
confirm that once it's all laid in place
somebody comes and inspects it um for in
a case he talked about in hener it was
the building inspect building code
inspector for the town but what does the
uh the evaluator do the septic syst
system evaluator what's their part in
this whole
process I don't know the answer to that
okay thank you is if you're watching
secret a secret from you all right uh
represent M yeah so does this the
evaluator also looks at the leeching and
all that stuff that's part of the whole
septic system okay I will say that this
bill wouldn't change the scope of
practice okay so it's really not
pertinent not pertinent okay so I made
the motion to keep this section as is I
need a
second all right uh
Brown um any more discussion need it
before we go to a vote I don't hear
anything all in favor I anyone
opposed okay thank you and if uh I'm
looking at this correctly we are done
except what I will do is like I did for
what can we go back to that inside there
yeah yes we did it so um as I did with
1410 I will finish that right up on the
changes it'll go to
oplc um for an
amendment and I will send it to
oplc and then I mean I could send out to
everybody as well at the same time and
that way you could catch anything I did
wrong Mr just for my clarification so we
did do the occupant license and family
mediator that was not done or that was
let which one the acupuncture
licensing and that was done as an
Advisory board or which one is that I
don't the number one and two oh yeah we
did that the first one number one and
two the family mediator I don't remember
the family mediator we finished this
morning we worked on last time and that
was the guardian and light them stuff oh
okay alls no no yeah I think so let me
finish with the process so I I will send
it to ol I will get an amendment and
it's some other sub committee meeting I
will add this bill at the top and then
we can formally vote to adopt the
whatever oplc comes up with our fine
problems Mr chair uh Guardian at Liam is
number three we didn't do number two
converts the board of family mediator we
did actually we did although today no
earlier um at least that's in my
records um we we did that right in order
we went we went in ordered through
everything the only thing that went out
of order was the massage therapist and
and the and eliminating the uh medical
technicians one since we got rid of that
in
um that's we're trying to settle on
whether that's everybody's in agreement
on
that
um no I don't think that's a requirement
although I um so are are we okay on this
we're good okay I'm going to close the
um subcommittee work session House Bill
1271 um and as I said we'll one of the
other ones I schedule I'll put at the
beginning once I've got a a uh thing
from oplc and we can have the approve it
hopefully so do you want to the schule
now uh no what I asked to I don't want
to look at it here what I want to do is
have everybody tell me when they're
available or not available for the week
the week of March 4th and the early part
of the following
week because Carol wants to exact all
the bills by March 13th or actually is
that maybe the full following week
actually I should
say let me what email I cannot remember
anything uh March 13th is yeah she's got
EXA so so here's here's the deal um
anything we have left we're going to
have to complete before March 13th and
we're not going to meet the week of the
24th through the 3 and so I'm hoping as
as many days as possible in that first
week of March and the first couple
days of the next week that you know
people be available but let me know and
what I'll do is I'll take
hopefully um all the days that we're all
available and if that's not enough I'll
have to talk to Carol if we can get
somebody else as a sub um because we
have to get done and also as I said I I
was worked to get rid of some of our
bills off to other subcommittees and but
the big thing is we have to do um well
we got 12:22 and I think 1408 you'll get
a new if it hasn't come out yet you'll
get a new notice and we'll start next
Tuesday with um 1408 which is another 40
some page thing like this and we're off
tomorrow uh correct because they're off
tomor little quick announcement Glen
before our Black Sheep had triplets this
morning one year old two of them weren't
deing well but Bill is committed to
helping me get he to so I'm praying say
prayers for two that aren't doing well
they
trip I don't know what's typical uh for
sheep well Finn she multiple verse are
typical and I talked to the Midwife lady
she was
mention
men and the emails come out for the
revision to Tuesday's meeting so it's
12:22 and 140 and we'll dive into 1408
and get as far as we can if we can get
it all done I'll try I'll be happy but
so yeah actually what people might want
to do do is you know take a look at
those um two bills so at least you have
some thoughts right on where to go with
consolidate because we're gonna be
laughing see hey if you don't laugh
about stuff you know you might as well
you can have fun anywhere you know all
right and thank you everybody for being
here we did close the thing so you're
you're not trapped although you're
welcome to watch our banter thank you
representative Dolan for participating
nice
jss
yeah